in our study of the different types of
markets we are now going to dive a
little bit deeper and understand perfect
competition
now this notion of something being
perfectly competitive you might have a
general idea of what it means you might
feel like it's very competitive that
there's a lot of people there maybe
competing for your business or maybe
there's a lot of buyers and there are a
lot of sellers and that is generally
true but we're trying to be economists
here so we want to be very precise with
our language so when economists talk
about perfect competition they're
talking about this somewhat very
abstract state where you have many
buyers and sellers
many
sellers
and buyers
now that doesn't seem too abstract so
far we can imagine a lot of markets that
have many sellers and buyers
now another thing that defines perfect
competition from an economics point of
view is that they're selling identical
identical products or services
products
products or services
now this one seems a little bit harder
because even when you can imagine a
fairly competitive market does everyone
sell exactly the same thing well you can
imagine certain markets maybe the market
for water or maybe the market for
some type of energy or maybe the market
for produce gets pretty close to
identical products or services so so far
it doesn't seem like that abstract of a
thing
now another aspect of perfect
competition is that every agent so that
would be the buyers the sellers the
producers the consumers they have
perfect information
perfect
information now what does perfect
information mean it means that every
participant in the market the buyers and
the sellers they all know exactly what
is happening in the market so what goods
or services are selling for what price
and who is selling to whom
so once again this gets a little bit
more abstract because to get truly
perfect information you can't not
everyone in a market will always know
everything that's going on so once again
this is a little bit of an abstract idea
that economists have introduced to be a
little bit more precise
and the last aspect we're going to talk
about and this is also something that is
a bit idealized that doesn't truly exist
in the real world some things close to
this exist in the real world is that
there's no
barriers
barriers to entry
or exit now we already mentioned some
markets say the market for agriculture
that doesn't quite have no barriers to
entry or exit you would somehow have to
get land you would have to get seeds you
would have to get fertilizer you would
have to hire people to put the seeds in
and to harvest the crops and so almost
any industry any market you imagine will
have some barriers but this is an
idealized notion that economists like to
think about and of course in the real
world things might approach this or be
closer to perfect competition than say
other markets but when you're in this
situation let's analyze what will be
happening
so we can look at the market as a whole
for whatever this product and services
so let me draw
price versus quantity here
for the market as a whole
so this is price
and this is quantity and this is
the market
right over here
and so we've seen this multiple times in
our economics journey that you have an
upward sloping supply curve and once
again this is for the entire market let
me do this in a different color
so
you have an upward sloping supply curve
like that and you would have a downward
sloping demand curve
like that
and we know what the equilibrium price
and quantity would be for the market so
this right over here would be the
equilibrium
equilibrium quantity for the market and
this right over here
would be the equilibrium price
for the market
now how would this affect
the the decisions for the firm in
perfect competition
well let's draw
let's draw a similar analysis but now at
the firm level
so
on this axis you could view this for the
firm and so this is going to be the firm
right over here one of the participants
in the perfect competition one of the
producers one of the sellers so on this
axis you could view this as price you
could also view this as
marginal
revenue
and
you could also view this as marginal
cost because we're going to plot
different curves
here
and then on the
horizontal axis we're going to have
quantity again but this is once again
the quantity that the firm
produces
now
first of all we can think about the
marginal cost for the firm and we've
seen this multiple times
that the marginal cost for the firm it
might look something like this
it over time
might trend upwards something like this
where at some point every incremental
unit is costing more and more to produce
maybe it's harder to get the resources
harder to get the labor or whatever you
want to say so that's the marginal cost
curve fairly typical for a firm
and then we could think about their
average total cost
and so
the average total cost curve might look
something like this let's draw it
something like this
so our average
total cost we've seen this multiple
times
now what is going to be the marginal
revenue for this firm that is operating
in perfect competition
well when it's operating in perfect
competition it just has to be a price
taker so every unit it sells is just
going to get the market price for that
unit
so in perfect competition the firm every
participant that is really identical in
a lot of ways they're just going to take
that price think about it they won't be
able to charge any more for their
product or service than the market price
because their product or service is
identical to everyone else's and
everyone knows it because of perfect
information and they would have no
motivation to charge less either they're
just passive you could view it that way
when it comes to price
so
if we just take this market price across
just like that
this right over here this price is going
to define the marginal revenue curve for
that firm so let me make this a bold
curve right over here
this is going to be the marginal revenue
for the firm for every unit it sells on
the margin that's how much more revenue
it's going to get now you could also
view this as the demand curve for the
firm's product you could also view this
as the average revenue for the firm's
product and let me make this clear this
is for the firm
demand for the firm which is equal to
the price that the firm actually gets
so the big takeaway here is in perfect
competition which is this somewhat
idealized state that doesn't quite exist
in the real world certain markets can
approach it the firms are passive price
takers they have no say on what the
price is going to be and so it would be
rational for them to just produce where
their marginal cost intersects with
their marginal revenue because anything
more than that then for every
incremental unit they're going to be
spending more money than they get in
terms of revenue and this passivity goes
a little bit against some of our
everyday notions of fierce competition
when we think about fierce competition
we often think about many players trying
to constantly undercut each other and in
future videos we'll talk about scenarios
where that might happen and you might
think about whether or not you would
want certain markets to have perfect
competition because no barriers to entry
means that frankly anybody could get
into that industry so for example you
might not want perfect competition when
it comes to someone being say your
doctor because you want barriers to
enter you want some level of training
you want some level of experience before
someone gets into that service